hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Lego Batman Easter egg and
references video careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the movie yet I'm not
even going to try and do the Will Arnett
intro movie should begin with scary
titles I can't do that gravelly voice
really well but there was a joke about
every ridiculous Batman character every
movie every TV show anything you could
possibly make fun of this movie did that
in every single line of dialogue
it was crazy there were probably a ton
of Easter eggs that I missed but there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Batman comment on
this video here we go they're about 50
of these not including all the different
characters from the Batman Canon there
was a really ridiculous ones too so
number one the plane hijacked at the
beginning of the film is from MacGuffin
airlines just the idea that there's this
plot device driving things forward it
doesn't really mean anything it's just
something to get the plot to move
forward to the airplane is owned by
Ferris air Carol Barrett's star sapphire
and girlfriend of Green Lantern Hal
Jordan which showed up during the
Justice League sequences number three
Commissioner Gordon's partner is named
O'Hara a reference to chief O'Hara
played by Stanford rep I'm just going to
go ahead and stop numbering these I'm
just going to list these because there's
so many both egghead and condiment King
completely ridiculous Batman villains
but totally true to the series so
condiment King showed up during the
animated series egghead was played by
Vincent Price on the classic TV show
they did a whole bunch of special lego
end cards for the DC TV shows which I'll
just play here Batman move your head
Killer Croc swine I did something is a
reference it's bit of a dig at Killer
Croc and Suicide Squad who almost did
nothing to service the plot
Doug Benson was the person voicing Bane
he did Dark Knight Rises Bane but he
also does that voice in real life all
the time on his podcast Doug loves
movies The Joker's line want to get nuts
obviously a reference to Michael
Keaton's Batman from the 89 film when
Joker asked Batman who you're number one
bad guy is and he starts talking about
Superman that's a dig at Batman V
Superman there's a sign for Batman
forever for the 1995 film that shows up
there's a building downtown called
Shrek's department store which is from
Batman Returns the second Michael Keaton
film in the Batcave there's a lot of the
Easter eggs from the Batcave in the
comics the giant t-rex is sitting there
that's from the 1946 Batman comic
dinosaur island the photo of Batman's
parents taken in front of the monarch
theatre is also true to the comics when
Alfred is getting down on Batman for the
different phases he goes through they
flash to every single Batman movie
that's ever happened in Lego with the
exception of the Superfriends cartoon
the cartoon logo the live-action bat
dance from the 60s TV series in the 1943
serial the original Batman serial
they made Superman's fortress of
solitude look just like the one in the
Richard Donner film there's a name drop
for blüdhaven when Barbara Gordon
appears for the first time home to
Nightwing there's an ad on the back of a
magazine called Barris automotives it's
a hat tip to George Barris the person
who designed the Batmobile from the 60s
TV series the laundry truck that reads
operated by Quinzel is actually a
reference to Harley Quinzel but then
later it reads Phantom Zone just a
reference to Superman's Phantom Zone
there were a bunch of outfits including
Batman costume robbing costumes that go
all across the cannons at the characters
war when we see Dick Grayson he's
dressed just like 1960s Dick Grayson in
that red shirt the scene where Alfred
less dick into the Batcave on purpose is
very reminiscent of Vicki Vale being let
into the Batcave on purpose it was a
Batman Beyond costume for everybody
that series that showed up when they
were doing the dressing montage the
glasses that Dick Grayson wears when
he's dressed as Robin make him look just
like the Carrie Kelly version of Robin
even though he's Dick Grayson when they
powered up the Batmobile they say atomic
batteries to power turbines to speed
that's what they would say when they
were powering up the Batmobile from the
60s TV series when they go to the
fortress of solitude the doorbell rings
the John Williams theme that was so
great
the banner on the fortress of solitude
reads 57th annual Justice League party
this year is the 57th anniversary of the
Justice League and it was the same thing
for the Joker too he says this is our 70
plus anniversary it's been 70 plus years
since the Joker debuted in the comics
there were a bunch of dance party Easter
eggs wonder dog is the DJ and they had a
couple characters from the challenge of
the Superfriends show Apache chief and
black Vulcan in the background when
Batman turns on the fortress of solitude
looking for crystals throwing them
Marlon Brando's message comes on from
the John Williams movies Batman drops a
gleaming the cube reference when Robins
trying to steal the Phantom Zone
projector he dumps his utility belt out
as he's trying to enter the prison they
have a Total Recall x-ray machine where
they have a fight is right out of that
Schwarzenegger movie the sheer number of
villains that pour out of the Phantom
Zone is ridiculous so we have Baltimore
but you know that Alfred is being played
by Ralph Fiennes who played Voldemort in
the Harry Potter movies so you have to
Voldemort's in the movie you have
godzilla you have King Kong you have
British robots that got the biggest
laugh out of me I don't know why they
weren't able to call them Daleks maybe
it was a copyright reason but they also
had flying monkeys from The Wizard of Oz
pretty much every genre villain that you
could possibly imagine there was even
jaws which was a nice callback to the
shark repellent from the 60s TV series
oh look it was useful is a sign for
penguin club the iceberg lounge that
shows up the Gotham Gazette shows up
that's also where Vicki Vale worked
during that Michael Keaton Batman film
they have a whole bunch of sodor Cola
which sounds weird but it's just a
fictional DC Comics soft drink that
first bat suit that Alfred shows up in
before he switches to his Butler Batman
costume is from the 1960s TV series
there is a huge Suicide Squad gig during
the movie when Batman's in the prison
and laughed at the idea of using
criminals to fight other criminals then
the Joker drops another Jack Nicholson
reference where does he get all those
wonderful toys the gremlins on the wing
is actually a reference to Twilight Zone
William Shatner loses hilarious to see
them in the movie this one's actually
really obscure let me know if you guys
picked up on the gymkata reference is
this really funny movie about someone
who fights crime and is a badass with
his gym skills so he does a lot of high
kicks a lot of slits it's just the most
ridiculous movie ever
the Batman family that Batman is so
afraid of putting together is actually a
big thing in the comics there's a lot
more Robins a lot more other people that
we're back costumes that are part of the
family now but this was just one of the
earliest versions of the bat family
Robin almost puts on a Nightwing costume
when he's talking about what would
Batman do Nightwing was the version of
Robin that he became in the comics when
they wanted to make him hardcore he was
growing up they wanted to put him in
Teen Titans so they give him a more
hardcore costume a more hardcore
attitude so when he saying I need to be
like Batman
that's what that costume was all about
the really awesome one you had to be
listening really closely but to face in
the movie is voiced by Billy Dee
Williams who played to face in the
Michael Keaton Batman film but never
actually got to be two-face he was only
Harvey Dent he never got acid in the
face so he never got to be that evil
persona and probably one of the funniest
but most on the nose Easter egg
references was the entrance password to
the Batcave Ironman sucks which is a dig
of the fact that Iron Man's another
billionaire in the comic book universe
that uses his money to fight crime so
let me know in the comments what other
Easter eggs did you guys find but it was
a great movie I think as long as you
understand that it's going to be
ridiculous going into it and I think
it's a little more rewarding for
longtime Batman fans just noticing an
easter egg in every single line of
dialogue it was crazy I feel like I'm
going to have to go back and see it
again just to catch a couple more than I
missed the first time but that aside I'm
not planning on doing a big review video
I feel like this movie doesn't need it
you pretty much know what you're getting
just based on the premise it's going to
be ridiculous but as long as you
understand that it'll be a lot of fun so
congratulations to the newest flash ring
giveaway winner Cory Thacker please
private message me on
back into my channel so I can get your
contact details what's gonna happen
tomorrow is Walking Dead is back so I'll
post my new episode video there'll be a
new Game of Thrones so be sure to look
out for that while you wait for the to
post you can click here to catch up with
all the crazy Marvel stuff to drop last
night for infinity vork and you can
click here for my latest flash video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video